It actually benefits us when we let our our legal system and
our institutions degrade. It actually benefits us. Are you an
accelerationist? >> There's nothing bad faith about it.
You just can't contend with the arguments >> that you that
is that shows how small your mind is that you think I can't contend
with that. IT IS A [laughter] >> WHAT CREATORS do you watch
that hand you this slop and send you into the world? Cuz clearly
you would never have thought of that on your own.
If I go to the wick panel, [music] this was a
this was a soy pill versus some guy panel. Okay. [laughter]
At the soy pill, desperately calling for backup, Pisco Litty
comes charging to the rescue. Will it be enough? Oh. Oh, was
Soy Bill getting destroyed? Was Soy Bill did Soy Bill get obliterated?
I guess I'll watch and see if that's actually what happens. I
I would love to see. We'll watch a little bit off the bat to
get a flavor and then I might jump forward to where the content
comes in. Okay. >> What should the liberal response be
to the Trump administration apparently subpoenaing
subpoenaing Hassan [__] What should our stance uh
be on the US's relationship with countries like Cuba? I'm going
to hand the mic first to Mr. Soyill and then we'll let Bishop
uh introduce himself. So Soy Pill, go ahead. What are your thoughts?
>> Uh it's irrelevant what his his behavior is. It's pretty
irrelevant to me if he even did break a law here because what
seems obvious to me is this is an >> it's so easy to understand
actually we should uphold our norms around enforcing you know
freedom of speech, freedom of interaction, freedom of transaction,
freedom of association, right? We should uphold these norms and
these like these things. We shouldn't punish somebody who is
trying to go and help people,
right? That those aren't liberal values. Those aren't my values
to just laugh when one of your enemies is jailed. Well, hey,
how do you know you won't be jailed for that same thing?
You go to do something kind. You go to do a nice thing and people
who are malicious want to weaponize that against you.
What happened to being a a regular human being, a good a good
person? What happened to that? Administrative crackdown trying
to introduce some sort of chilling effect. They're not applying
the standard over every single person that was on that uh convoy.
They're not doing it to their own partisan pundits like Nick
Shirley who might have stayed in a sanctioned hotel. This is
just an attack to try to silence critics and you should look
at it as a fascist government and an authoritarian move and oppose
it regardless of who they're doing it to. Yeah. >> Okay.
Glad to have you and $10 from pondering politics to say askill
the steel man Joe's definition of populism. Uh we'll say that
for the maybe the uh the meat of the discussion, but uh thanks
for being here. We're going to get into it as we go. Uh next
up, we're going to give the mic to Mr. Bishop. Go >> Hey
everybody, it's [clears throat] Bishop here. Self-described locky
liberal. Um I uh I do a I'm a defense contractor by day and a
poster on Twitter by night. Um and uh my take on the Hassan situation
is that um I I believe that a lot of the uh a lot of the dialogue
around Hassan right now is talking about the illegitimacy of
the government and the illegitimacy of like obviously in my opinion
a fascist type government uh and uh unwieldy uh use of our institutions.
However, I still think that it's very important that we don't
throw out the baby with the bathwater and um and just completely
discredit any any kind of a subpoena put out by federal law enforcement.
Um, and I think the the point that I think really needs to be
argued, >> oh, so this guy's going to argue something.
It's like, okay, maybe there's a actual underlying like fundamental
purpose there,
sure, but like we'd have to see some evidence of that, right?
I don't mind that. I don't mind that the people look into this
but the way the media is jumping on it and the way the government
hasn't cleared anything up or hadn't cleared anything up, that
seems concerning to >> And with that, I guess we'll get
into it. Can can you give us uh maybe elaborate a little bit
more on that serious cause? Do we think that the subpoena may
be legitimate? What what are your thoughts on that? Go ahead.
>> I think the question is what is legitimate and what
is illegitimate? I I believe that now in the year of 2026 what
we have across many different legal domains is we have a series
of rules, regulations and laws. And uh what we wind up having
is we wind up having situations where people will break a law
and then maybe they'll be pursued and said, "Okay, well now we're
going to hold you accountable. You did break the law." But the
problem is that nobody is prosecuted for that law. And so I think
one of the main ways people are looking at this is they're like,
"Oh, well maybe Hassan violated sanctions, but number one, I
we don't know if we agree with the sanctions in the first place.
And number two, uh like what we're seeing with this Turning Point
USA kid, we it doesn't appear that the violations of these sanctions
are being applied evenly. Therefore, it is targeted." And um
while I think that there is certainly some truth in the unequal
application of of those uh violations, it really brings me to
think about the situation with Al Capone. And don't get me wrong,
I do not think that Hassan, >> Dude, if you mention Al
Capone in reference to Hassan. Oh, well, he's really bad, so
let's get him on something. Listen,
I we just all need to remember, okay? Anybody who's taking this
position, I want to say anybody who's taking this position where
you are claiming to be a liberal, but you're denigrating your
own principles to go after Hassan because you think he's bad,
you don't like him. Anybody who's doing that, man, I feel like
I'm not gonna I'm not going to shed a tear when it comes to you.
I'll probably fight it. I'll probably say it's wrong, but I'm
not I'm certainly not going to shed a tear. I'll say that's wrong.
That's wrong.
No, don't do that. I'll probably say it more forcefully. I'll
probably just totally caning actually defend the person it happens
to. But my god, these people suck, man. I I will probably because
it's just what you have to do ultimately. That's the position
you have to have is oh these people are using the government
to go after people and they're they're basically breaking with
norms, breaking with rules to do it. They are violating all the
norms that exist. They are not applying the law evenly. And if
I support that even in the case of somebody I despise,
then it can be used against me. Although not me because I live
in another country, but it could be used against
And so don't think of it as protecting that person you hate.
Think of it as protecting yourself or your loved ones. That's
who you're protecting when you stand up for Hassan [__]
Your loved ones, not you. Sorry, not Hassan. You're standing
up for yourself, your loved ones, your colleagues.
Do you get it?
How hard is this to understand? Is Alapone. I want to be clear.
Alapone killed people. Hassan is just a streamer. Um, but we
understand that the way they went after Alapone, the way they
got him was for tax evasion. And we understand that he he wasn't
targeted by the IRS that the IRS was randomly like, "Oh, hey,
we think this guy might have a problem with his taxes." The problem
is he was causing all these other problems and taking advantage
of all these loopholes with with the liberties that are afforded
in a liberal society as opposed to an authoritarian state. He
was taking advantage of them. And so we understand that they
had to do they had to apply some of these rules that he was breaking
to address the greater problem which was to get him off the street.
Now I I say all this, >> don't you feel like totally insane?
a guy who abetted like dozens and dozens and dozens of murders,
all kinds of crimes across like the the entire Midwest. And you're
like, "Yeah, that's basically like Assad [__] We
we need to get Hassan [__] so badly off the street
so badly that we need to just like fundamentally shift away from
all norms to do it." Like, I don't know. Why would you Okay,
you argue that you better argue to go after Trump. You better
basically be arguing that like Trump needs to be gone day one,
right? Come on, man.
the threshold, the legal threshold for it to be a criminal
is actually outrageously high. So, I don't think we're even really
at that level. But I do think that um the uh the hostile nature
of the Cuban government and the Cuban island is unbelievably
like uh not talked about. A lot of people talk about Cuba as
if, oh, it's just another island down there and we had like a
shaky past with them. But to >> this already, this started
off totally insane that this guy like basically makes an argument
where he's like, "Oh, well, you know, maybe there's an argument
that they're applying the law unevenly and maybe this is like
really up." But also, if you considered Al
you got to know that you are in an argument. Okay, if if what
Wick said is true and Soy Pill is truly getting his his blown
out and he had to call for help from Pisco,
that seems kind of tragic. That seems kind of embarrassing. I
hope that's not the case, man. I sure hope not >> to not
go on and on and on. Um the fact of the matter is according to
uh Hassan the the trip was organized with the Cuban government.
So this was a Cuban government approved political program and
uh in it being a political program that means that the uh Cuban
military and intelligence services were somewhat involved. Even
if that means that their involvement was we approve uh it means
that they were involved and I I think that's uh way more serious
than anybody's talking about right now. >> Yeah. Uh so
a few things. My understanding is not only did he approve this
with the Cuban government cuz yeah know you have to let the government
know before you take a giant ship full of 20 tons of supplies
and drive it up to their border. So of course they let them know.
He also went through OFAC the office of foreign assets commission
or whatever that stands for. So he's went through the same government
that is subpoenaing him right now. So the idea that this is like
some Cuban coordinated back deal to subvert American interest
is pretty ridiculous to me. Uh the second thing is this subpoena
isn't
so it's going to be one of those debates where they found somebody
to argue totally insane and obviously there's only one person
arguing like dude get somebody in here who can actually argue
cuz holy like this isn't going to be a debate. It's just going
to be this guy making a total ass of himself the entire time
making zero good points. You know what I mean? Like this guy's
just going to continuously embarrass himself. At least let Wick
2v1 at least. I hope Wick at least 2v1's with against Soy Pill
because otherwise soy just gets to sit back and be like, "Yeah,
uh, so here's like the fundamental thing we all believe in and
I don't know why I even have to point this out." And the other
GUY'S LIKE, "WELL, HAVE YOU considered that Al Capone is kind
of like Hassan Piker?"
No, that's a totally insane thing. I didn't consider that because
it's a completely insane thing to say. I didn't entertain that
or consider it because you'd have to be on mushrooms to consider
that. You'd have to be on acid. you would have to be out of your
mind on drugs to consider that. So, I didn't consider it cuz
I'm sober right now.
Isn't alleging a crime even. It's just, hey, let's go after you
by looking into you, assuming that you did something bad, but
we're not sure yet. Which is very clearly like, let's, you know,
try to investigate this person to produce some sort of chilling
effect. And third, you did this whole alapone thing. Uh, well,
what's the alapone equivalent that Hassan is doing right now
that is like, well, this guy's doing something illegal that we
can't get him through and it's a loophole, so let's go after
him. The thing he's doing is talking [__] about the
government. He's about Democrats. He's on Trump and you do not
like that, and that's fine. I don't like some of the stuff he
says, and in fact, I don't like a lot of the stuff he says. But
I would never say, and this is why we need to find some sort
of legal loophole like, "Hey look, you put 55 in a 50 zone. Let's
lock him the up." That doesn't justify. So, what do you think
justifies what he's doing right now that the Cuban government
colluded with him to subvert American interest or some sort of
insane, you know, like back deal here that you think is actually
worth arresting this person over or what he's doing outside of
this that this side not real like thing, but this like side project
to arrest him is worth arresting him over? >> Well, let's
let's start off with some ground ground terms here. We're not
talking about a legal loophole. A lot of people are using a lot
of this loose language to talk around the issues. This is not
a loophole. I went to Cuba personally and when I went to Cuba
I kept a notebook with me and I documented every single thing
that I did because the the legal uh permissions that I went to
Cuba with asan noted are very strict and guess what when I came
back I was questioned on it. This is not some legal loophole
that somebody is, oh well, technically everybody's it's 55. It's
actually very serious. And going to an island that is actively
involved in military and intelligence operations is perhaps the
most aggressive intelligence
entity uh addressing the United States consistently houses. >> Oh,
so if you've got an aggressive intelligence agency that operates
in the United States, you'd want to like basically treat that
that entity like a hostile entity, like not an ally at all. Oh
well.
Well, well, well. Let's see if this is applied evenly in this
conversation. >> Chinese and Russian intelligence facilities.
Um, this isn't this isn't a joke. And by the way, to put this
into comparison because like I said, we keep on talking over
Cuba like, "Oh, it's it's just like some interest. It's just
some interest." If somebody went to Russia and started uh spending
money at Russian militaryowned premises and then they came back
and they said, "Hey, we're going to look into
whether you you violated any sanctions." I don't think anybody
would be freaking out about it. In fact, I think most people
would be saying, "Hey, wait, what? You spent money on a Russian
military?"
Wait, but that's isn't that way different that they cleared the
whole trip with the American government beforehand? Isn't it
like a way different situation organization? Maybe we should
look into it. And like you said, I think it's right. Number one,
>> look into it for what what's the >> to see if
to see if uh well, I think the risk here is that he is collaborating
with Cuban uh intelligence uh intelligence apparatus. I mean,
one of the main things uh one of the main things that he said
when he uh and one of one of the main things we were talking
about that he said was that the Cuban government reached out
to him through an intermediary about having consistent internet
access. So, but like through an intermediary who would be a FAR
agent, I assume like somebody who could lobby or somebody who
could represent the Cuban government. Like I I thought this was
literally somebody through like OFAC. No. >> What is going
on with him having consistent military a consistent uh internet
access and consistent power access on an island in the middle
of a blackout? Was that a military network? Was that a military
generator? And if he was on the military network, what if all
the FBI wants is possession of his laptop to start going through
the records of getting to the bottom of uh the details of that
military uh int military internet network? There's there's like
20 dozen different things here and Assad himself has said and
this really seems to be the case. He is not the target. He doesn't
think he's the target. I don't think he's the target. It seems
like it honestly it seems like Code Pink isn't even the target.
It seems like the target might be whoever the main financial
backers are of Code Pink. And to sit here and say that an intelligence
agency has absolutely no interest in a uh in a series of influence
operations that are addressing ongoing military conflicts, I
don't I don't understand how we can sort of live in that world
where it's like why would the FBI interest? >> So this
to me is one of those things where people will look at the laws
on the books or immigration and say, "Well, of course they broke
the law. Don't you think they have an interest in investigating
the laws that they broke?" And you're kind of deferring to like
these laws that exist, which by the way haven't always existed
and changed significantly under Obama and then were reversed
in 2017. And then to say that this is not some sort of agenda-driven
thing to me is belying the point that this is clearly an agenda
driven thing and whether or not they're targeting Hassan Copink.
The point of this is to, you know, use them as this sort of surrogate
for we're attacking Cuba and and the conversation right now is
being centered on should Hassan get in trouble for this. If you
think there's a good faith effort by an intelligence agency to
go through Hassan's computer to find potential adversarial information,
maybe this is to totally possible. Do you think that's why he's
being centered at at these articles? Do you think that's why
the conversation is centered entirely around him and not what
you're saying? because you're giving the most good faith possible
interpretation of what an administration might be doing, which
is to me absolutely ridiculous given everything we've seen come
out of the Trump administration. Like you would have to be delusional
to say anything like this is that unless it's on paper and ignoring
the last 8 years of Trump that we've seen. >> Well, one
one of the things that I I when I listen to you and a panel of
people speak about this on live and learn, I I noticed that everybody's
initial response was well, this is coming out of the Trump administration,
so we immediately need to completely discredit it. And while
I think that uh large political things coming from the Trump
administration warrant >> I will I will get to it. Okay.
>> Serious scrutiny. they weren't seriously uh sec going
back over some things. I think it's utterly ridiculous to live
in a world where we don't like the president so we're just going
to discredit literally everything that happens from the government
period because there's no real difference.
>> What what's what else is being discredited right now?
It's just saying hey you're going after like some kind of influencer
and that's not even the case by the way. I just think right now
I don't know what the government is doing. I do think it's okay
to meet the Trump administration scrutiny of opposition to their
party with total
like
derision with with you assume it's false until they show why
they're doing it. That is the most appropriate way to handle
it because they've been shown to be bad faith actors in so many
cases. You know what I'm saying? >> I I mean that's essentially
army. You said they've got to be delusional to >> what
what information do you think that they'll get out of Hassan's
laptop that they couldn't get through the entire military intelligence
apparatus that they're already doing with spying? Intercepting
communications. Why do you think they're subpoenaing specifically
Assan and Code Pink? And why do you think these people the ones
being highlighted by Fox News, which by the way happened before
Assan or Code Pink have confirmed they even got a subpoena? So,
this is a sensationalized article to try to get ahead of something
that might not have even happened yet. Maybe it's going to happen
or maybe it never will happen, but let's say it will. This is
meant to drum up anti, hey, look at these leftwing people sentiment
clearly. >> Yeah. Yeah. Absolutely. Yeah. So, I one of
the things that we're talking about here is like is this politically
targeted? And it reminds me about conversations when people talk
about terrorism. Oh, well, it's such a political thing about
what is terrorism and what isn't terrorism. Terrorism by definition
is political. So of course it's political. So this dialogue about
like oh well the only reason
>> uh this guy is just trying to talk in
>> They're targeting Assan is because he went to Cuba because
there's a huge military confrontation with Cuba right now. It's
like yeah that's >> okay but you're immediately be confronted
with the fact that they did not go after Nick Shirley in the
same
>> And so explain that discrepancy. >> How things
work when you
that's not what I'm alleging. I'm alleging they're going to sign
because he's a leftwing streamer, not because he went to Cuba,
right? Nick Shley went to Cuba. He went to a sanctioned hotel.
>> Yeah. So stupid, man.
Am I just going to watch this guy punch himself in the face repeatedly
for the next hour?
>> Tell and they're not subpoenaing him to my knowledge.
>> For sure. And I think it's very clear that they are
not going after Nick Shirley because Nick Shirley is friendly
to the regime. But they are not going after Hassan just because
he's leftwing because if they were, they'd be going after every
single major leftwing commentator that didn't go to Cuba. They're
going after Hassan because he's connected. He's low hanging fruit.
He's connected to code pink who has
>> didn't go to Cuba. That's the whole that's the whole
reason they're able to have this excuse to go after them. They're
going after other people that went on the flotilla or the convoy
that went to Cuba and they're using that as an excuse. Obviously,
it's not relevant that they went to Cuba. But this is what they're
using as the like, oh, and this is why we're allowed to go after,
right? Just like the your example with Alapone. It's like, well,
you did this. Now we have an excuse to punish. >> That's
another great point. You literally brought up Al Capone to make
an example of you, right? You you brought up Al Capone. Why would
you bring up Al Capone if you don't know if you don't in some
way like totally understand what's happening here? Why did the
name Al Capone even leave your
lips, bro?
>> Yeah. And and absolutely. I think like I don't understand
where the confusion here is. There's sort of like some allegation
that something nefarious is going on because people collaborate.
>> What could Soy just ask him why he brought up Al Capone?
I just need to know why did you bring up Al Capone? What was
the context? What were you trying to deliver to me? What information
were you attempting to help me understand when you brought up
Al
>> With the Cuban government and by definition with how
it works, the Cuban military and intelligence apparatus to go
on a political trip for the purposes of politics and then they're
being investigated upon it in what world. >> Wait, so name
something that doesn't apply to Nick Shirley right now. Name
something that doesn't apply. I assume if you're an American
going to Cuba, you got to clear a bunch of either with OFAC or
with the Cuban government. you know, just to get to go is like
a non-Cuban citizen to Cuba as an American, right? And never
clear anything with them. That's crazy.
That Well, I mean, I feel like you'd be taking a big risk doing
that, right? You take a bunch of camera equip equipment, you
smuggle yourself into Cuba. I feel like you'd be taking a massive
risk. No, >> I mean, honestly, it would not justice if
they weren't investigated for it. >> Do you think Do you
think there's like 5% the Trump administration tried to let Nick
Shirley get smuggled to Cuba hoping they just kill him? gives
him like a pretext to invade. [laughter] >> I'm gonna skip
forward. I'm skipping >> Oh, getting rid of him, right?
>> By the way, um >> who who are they dragging in?
>> I'll be honest. I'm gonna be honest with you. And then
maybe no one's going to disagree with this. I feel like we don't
need to ban Hassan. We don't need to feel bad for him either
at all. And to be honest, I don't even know why. I mean, even
if people do um cheer on it, I don't think it's bad cuz Hassan
is an enemy of us as well. And they're not going after like liberals,
I would say. So, I don't know there's any reason we need to defend
someone who will not defend us. And if anything, getting rid
of him, I mean, quote unquote, getting rid of him, right, would
help us in the long run anyway. So, if you look at like a net
benefit side, him being gone is the great greatest thing ever.
I'm not going to defend >> Wait, so Vicy, to be clear,
you wouldn't defend anyone for any sort of rights that you think
are like supposed to be of enforced for all Americans if you
didn't like them. >> No. Okay, that's a really Okay. >> Do
only disabled people call into Wick? This guy is a total [__]
It actually benefits us when we let our our legal system and
our institutions degrade. It actually benefits us. Are you an
accelerationist? What creators do you watch that hand you this
slop and send you into the world? Cuz clearly you would never
have thought of that on your own. That is a totally moronic argument
you just made. Whoever this guy is, wrong with this person. Dude,
>> I would defend him if it was anything >> that's
a Hutch mod.
Classic.
We don't have to feel bad for him. Nobody's telling you to feel
bad that Hassan's getting arrested. What I'm asking you to do
is go hassan,
but I'll defend him anyway.
It sure is funny that that guy's getting over, but I am going
to step in and defend him now because I don't want that to happen
to me.
I'm gonna step into and help him now because I don't want that
to happen to one of my friends.
That's what you do. You can laugh. You could go haha, but I'm
still going to defend him. >> The Cuba thing, I feel like
they have some form of legal avenue to do it and it could be
yes or no. I don't think it is straight up like just political.
I would say they literally advertised something that could >> Nobody
said it was just Nobody said that they made this up for no reason.
Hassan went to Cuba. They're saying they're applying the law
unevenly. When you come in and say, "Well, he technically did
go to Cuba and stuff." Yeah, nobody's disputing that. You are
just wasting time. You were just filibustering, wasting time
cuz you were a [__] it' be sanctioned. What? Like
sanction breaking or whatever. But if it was like for espionage
or something like that, I'll be like, "Okay, no, this is bad."
>> Well, then why do you have why do you have any smoke?
Dude, you can't make up that. You can't make up that that guy's
a hutch. Holy [__]
There's just there's no way that's a hutch,
dude. For Hassan doing it at all then, if you would do the same
back cuz I think what he says when he say he's like a, you know,
centrist Democrat getting arrested or having some dumb DOJ charges
thrown under him, that's bad, right? And then that's why I wouldn't
do it to Hassan. But you're saying, "No, actually, I I won't
have any smoke for a song cheering on Adam Schiff getting arrested
because that's what I think we should do." >> My problem
with that argument is that it's it draws a false equivalency.
It's sort of like, "Oh, yeah. You say you're tolerant. Well,
then why don't you tolerate my intolerance?" And it's like, "Look,
the same thing from different people are different things."
>> Yeah. One of them you agree with and the other one you
don't, but they're the same tactic, which is I don't care what
the charge is. If this gets rid of them, I'm okay with it. Right.
>> I just I just want to make my stance clear here, >> dude.
It's so stupid, man.
I understand how you let like let like your anger blind you sometimes.
Maybe
I get it. I get how you can let your anger blind you sometimes.
It makes some sense to me, but you got to you got to wake up
before you go on a debate panel and like sober up and figure
out what's actually important. You know what I mean? Like, oh,
I really hate this guy. Whatever. We keep watching. >> I
think that Vishy I I think that's the wrong way to go about it
and wrong way to think about it. This isn't like, oh, he didn't
defend us. We shouldn't defend him. No. The reason my mind changed
is because I was convinced and and and reminded of because again
I have worked in the military before that there were oh wow there's
a plausible legitimate reason that a subpoena could be issued
here that I think I cannot I do not have enough information to
say whether or not my distrust of the Trump administration overrides
that. And so I am like okay I think the legitimate reasons are
enough that I'm going to sit back stand by uh see what happens
here. I'm not going to take too strong of a stance yet. Um, I
think subpoenaing him could very well be entirely legitimate
and within America's interest. So, I'm just gonna Yeah, but my
my >> that could all be true. You should still say that,
hey, this is bad. Hey, investigating Hassan without like some
some very obvious pretext, some very obvious reason why. I'm
going to assume this politically motivated, right? I that could
be totally fine. That could be a reasoning for saying, "Well,
I'm very suspicious of this and I support Assan. I don't think
he should be jailed for anything he's done." Right? Like I don't
think he should be in trouble for anything he's done here. He
took aid to starving people. I don't want him prosecuted for
that in any way. But if they want to look through it for some
sort of intelligence reason, okay, that's fine with me.
>> I'm I'm kind of okay with that. I could be more okay
with that. Okay. Decision here isn't because oh, Hassan didn't
defend us, so we're not going to defend him. That's >> that's
not the main reason. I'm going to put a part of it. It's like
a minor reason, but I'm going to have that in there. Same way
like I would say for the >> Come on, please go. If you
want in, jump in, brother. >> I was I wasn't mad. I mean,
I was extremely bad when he went after Comey, even though I hate
Comey with all my heart because I feel like that was straight
up just like that was straight up just political warfare. I think
there is some validity to going after Assan. >> Like at
the end of the day, I hate Republicans more than I hate Assan.
So >> at I was so mad at Comey cuz I feel like I didn't
see any single reason for them to do it or any of those ex-Trump
guys that didn't like that didn't bend the knee at the very end.
They went after him. I didn't like that even though I can be
like, "Oh, who cares, right?" Um I think it's cuz they all went
after one single goal. Um, if I swear if this was like another
way they attacked us on for something else, I'd be like defending
it. I just think there is validity here, which is why I'm not
going to feel which I'm not even going to feel bad about. If
there is some validity
[__] up on her mortgage stuff, >> to be honest,
I don't know much about it. I don't think she did.
>> Don't Don't say do you think she did? Don't say that.
Say, what if she did? What if she did? Do you think it's appropriate
for the Trump government to push through to push through a grand
jury, an indictment that the actual attorney general or sorry,
the actual uh states attorney for that state didn't want to bring?
Do you think it's good for them to push their finger down, put
their thumb on the scale and push that indictment to happen,
right? Cuz let's say Leticia James did actually something up
there. But in a way, a ton of people something up. Should she
be prosecuted to the fullest extent of the law, which is what
they wanted to do? They just completely made it up. It was a
total lie. It wasn't. >> Oh, speaking of
[laughter]
Pisco is going to go silverback mode on this guy if he continues
on this route. Okay. Especially now that the Leticia James thing
has been brought up. >> Like maybe they found an error
>> I mean, possibly. I don't know much about it, so I'm
not going to speak on it. I don't want to do that. I don't >> go
look into it and then question whether or not you do the same
thing for Leticia James given that like, hey, wait, hold on.
You did technically break the law. It's fine. They're going after
her, right? Well, there's also a difference in getting something
wrong on your mortgage paperwork and collaborating with a hostile
foreign government to indoctrinate the American public by the
millions. There's
>> Wait, do you do you think that's what they're subpoenaing
for? Why would the Why would OFAC be the ones subpoenaing him
if that was the concern? Are you out of your mind? Why would
Why would the Office of Foreign Asset something
I need to remember what this is? Office of Foreign Assets Control.
Why would they be the ones subpoenaing him if that was the actual
concern? Are you out of your mind? Come on, man. >> You
haven't substantiated whatsoever. But okay. Yeah. >> Well,
actually, hold on. Pisco, uh, or soy pill, before you guys jump
in there, I actually have a a point. >> Pisco, shut the
up. Pisco sitting here has not SPOKEN YET. PISCO, SHUT UP. PISCO,
shut the up. Pisco, stop over. Do we know who funded the media
network that sponsored Hassan's trip to China? Because I feel
like >> a billionaire named Singum. >> Yeah. Do we
know if this person has any relation to who sponsored Code Pink
for the China flotilla or not the China flotilla, the Cuba flotilla?
Because in reality, this might not be about Cuba at all. This
could be about ties to the CCP, which is even more adversarial
to the US, which
I would say is a much stronger case, not necessarily against
Hassan, but would be a much more valid reason for a subpoena.
As far as the >> So, what's the reason? Wait, did somebody
pay? These guys are saying, are they implying there's like Hassan's
trip was paid for by somebody else.
Is there some evidence for this? >> Pina leaking to Fox
News, which I know is what Soy Pill is about to say. I just think
that was somebody being advantageous and selling a scoop to Fox
News and the administration for a few thousand bucks because
who the hell in this administr >> being advantageous
isn't getting rich on the public's dime
>> Okay. Please go. Hold on. Just before we go, please
go. I got some uh stuff. >> Oh, wait. A sponsor for the
visas is way different than a sponsor. A sponsor for a visa doesn't
pay you money. That's like that's a name. That's a word, but
it doesn't mean sponsor in terms of
>> Come on, man. Come on, dog. >> You got some thoughts?
>> Yeah, a little bit. Yeah. I just don't know what's wrong
with taking a negative inference against this administration.
Uh especially when it comes to, you know, subpoenas and targets
related to political actions. Are we supposed to be blind? ignore
the course of conduct of this administration as though they're
not I don't think anybody's argued that >> hang on a second.
So um I think when it relates to >> that's quite literally
the argument when you come and say well actually we don't know
if it's wrong yet that is the argument you're making. Pisco is
saying give uh them a negative inference immediately because
everything they've done so far has been totally corrupt and totally
your position of ignorance. I don't really know maybe it is legitimate
is actually an argument against what Pisco is saying
things like potential criminal investigations at this point in
the administration. It is your duty to make negative inference
against what the administration is doing to the extent that it
relates to you know politically relevant topics or politically
relevant uh individuals. You could always say, couldn't you,
at the subpoenas they gave to James Comey, for example, relating
to uh testimony he may have given to Congress. Well, there's
a potentially plausible um legitimate purpose and crime. Isn't
it a crime to lie under oath to Congress? I mean, that is a crime,
isn't it? And you cannot the >> Well, who who are you directing
this towards? I'm kind of curious. I >> I think Wick or
you to somebody were saying that it's improper to take a negative
inference against administration. Nobody said that. >> Quick,
Bishop, please. Uh to be clear, coming into this debate, I did
and I still have a negative um opinion of this. Like I I came
in skeptical because anything the Trump administration does deserves
a high degree of skepticism.
>> uh there has been >> So what evidence has caused
you to to overcome what what is overcome your skepticism, your
negative inference? What evidence is there that has overcome
>> been a great argument made by Bishop that oh the Cuban
government is a hostile government and there are very >> So
you just didn't know before this. You hadn't thought in that
pretty little brain of yours, Wick. Oh, well, the Cuban government
doesn't like America. Apparently, that slipped Wick's mind. Wick
didn't even think about that. When this entire argument was first
being made, Wick totally forgot that the Cuban government is
hostile to America. Really? So, you're like a complete You're
like a slobbering
worthless. Okay, fantastic. I guess we already knew that but
proof
something may have gone on that the America would have a interest.
>> I just totally forgot that like Cuba doesn't like America
that this guy made an amazing argument and said that Cuba doesn't
like America and I was like oh my god
maybe this is legitimate.
>> Yeah. Okay. Fantastic about So I think >> Do you
think that the Trump admin wick is more likely to have what you
just described or everything they've been displaying? It's a
coin toss after everything you've seen them do. >> The
difference between Comey indictment, the Comey indictment we
knew was because the plausibility of Comey having done what they
said was almost zero. However, the plausibility of the U of the
Cuban government and intelligence agencies trying to use Hassan
or get information from Hassan that it would be within our interest
to find out what they asked him or what they even talked to him
about is much much higher. Right. >> What would it take
to proper on that I guess if you always think that there's a
potential interest in the in the >> So again, okay, you
could say all of
>> So they should be subpoening Nick Shirley, right? >> So
again, the same investigation must be carried out in Nick Shirley
for the exact same reason.
Yes. Yes. If they are ignoring that, if they're not doing that
investigation into Nick Shirley, then something improper must
be happening here. If that was the only bar,
then surely ha
then surely Nick Shirley would be getting subpoenaed. >> Government
of United States to find out what Cuba said or talked to about.
What would it take for you to be like actually this is not good?
>> Well, if if uh as a result of their subpoena, they uh
do something like charge him for uh buying a hot dog from one
of the sellers there, right? Then that would be like, okay, this
was obviously and this shouldn't have happened and this was obviously
a political attack. But however, all they do is come in, ask
them, "Hey, did you talk to uh did you talk to this person?"
>> How about this? What did they ask? >> No, hang
on, hang on a second. No, I'm I'm saying with respect to the
subpoena itself, put aside any So, are you saying that only in
the context in which or one of the key instance which you could
see yourself disagreeing with the subpoena is if some charge
comes out of it? Um, but like is that are those really the only
circumstances under which you would question the the use of the
subpoena itself as as a device?
>> I think it's because it's Cuba. If it was like
>> this is Can I Can I real quick? >> Go ahead. I
apologize. Yeah. So, Pisco, number one, I wanted to say I think
you're right fundamentally with what you're saying. Perhaps uh
you know, the way that I've been wording it is anything political
coming out of this administration warrants extra scrutiny. I
think that's absolutely true. >> Oh, wait. That's not what
I said. Sorry, I didn't say extra scrutiny. >> Negative
inference. Their action should be viewed as disfavorable, as
not legitimate until proven legitimate. >> I said a negative
inference to be opposed to it unless and until you're shown some
strong evidence that's uh motivated by non bias.
>> What do you What do you mean by negative inference?
By negative energy, I mean a disposition that is against it,
not just extra scrutiny. >> Yeah, you're like, you're sounding
a lot like an election denier to me. That's just what that sounds
like. >> An election denier is not using a as a basis for
Pisu's opinion is all of the corruption, all of the weaponization
of the system that's been done so far. The election denier has
[laughter] he's about to I hear it. I hear it. He's He's He's
fueling up. Okay, he's he's getting into a rage. I can feel it
from here. I can feel the the anger. Okay. Just I can feel it
radiating through my screen. >> To me is you're just like
automatically you should assume that that's what it sounds like
to me. >> It's not at all like >> just automatically
>> go pieces but to tear this guy's arms >> inference
automatically we should distrust the election and
>> hang on a second. So it is sometimes rational to take
a negative disposition against a person or institution as a default
presumption. Yes or no?
>> That's so genuine.
Sometimes >> what do you mean what what do you mean by
inst Yeah. >> should frame it as do you have a principal
position against ever saying an institution shouldn't be trusted
at a fundamental level >> like do you have some sort of
position where it's like I will always assume the institution
is acting in good faith unless shown otherwise. If you have that
position then I don't need to argue >> Explain that more.
I'd love to answer. >> Yeah. So to disbelieve information
coming from a particular source until shown corroborating evidence.
It is sometimes rational to have that epistemic frame of reference.
Yes or no? Well, I I [laughter] don't think that's very clear.
I don't think it's clear. I don't think it's clear what you're
saying because you are applying you are applying this this uh
warranted negative inference to the Trump administration to the
actions of a subpoena from the FBI and that that's a very wide
net. Very wide net whoever
fine, whoever the sorry the federal government. So I'm happy
but I just want to clear up the air because you said that this
is this would be like taking a kind of negative inference against
election results and I'm trying to first clear that up to make
sure there's no confusion. That's not at all what I applied.
So you this notion No, just I just want to be clear about that.
It's not uh sort of included in my criticism in my application
of a negative inference regardless of its scope. It's not necessitated
or entailed that I would take that approach to election results.
Correct. >> So I don't know how wide your net is. Like
you're applying it to this this uh organ this federal organization
that issued this subpoena. Like where do where does it stop and
start with this
>> so I'm happy to get into the scope and and talk to you
about that. But it's just enough for you to say it's not entailed
that I take this epistemic view and this negative inference in
the context of elections. Right. That's not >> I I I think
it is entailed because you haven't substantiated how wide your
net >> Well, no, it's possible. It's it's narrow such that
it doesn't include elections. Correct. >> No, you haven't.
You haven't >> substantiated. Wait, wait. Sorry. You're
arguing with me, dude. I'm not asking. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. I'm
not I'm not saying that I have substantiated. I'm asking is it
possible for one to have this negative inference?
>> Possible. Yes. I'm asking you. This is the third time.
I'm asking. >> So, I'm telling you asking four times or
>> Yes. So, so what I'm telling you is I don't have that
view for election results. Okay. >> So, so that's what
I'm trying to sus out. So, is it just elections? Is it just the
dirty word? Is it just the one that makes you sound stupid that
you don't agree with? Or is there a line
>> Why didn't Pio just say that there's like a track record
that I'm basing this on? Did he not say that already? That I
have like an actual track record that I'm basing this on, that
this government has come in and totally every norm and rule that
exists. Feels very easy to do >> No, no. The negative inference
is makes sense to apply whenever it makes sense to apply it,
right? To the extent that it makes sense to apply it. It doesn't
make sense to apply it in the context of elections. Yeah. So,
it makes sense to apply. That's what Sorry. That's what he is
saying. He's just saying it's obvious. It's like self-evidently
a negative inference to >> no peace code. This guy is like
slobbering on his he he like slobbered on his keyboard and shortcircuited
his camera. You need to speak slowly for him. You need to like
lay it out very slowly, very nicely. All right. Very neatly,
chill, and just lay out the facts for this guy >> to government
actions or justifications in the context in which the government
consistently lies and is corrupt. So in that context it makes
sense to apply negative inference and that's not true when it
comes to election results largely run by state governments.
>> No, I don't I fundamentally don't agree. I think there's
>> uh [screaming] what what do you Okay. So then show me
the corruption coming from state
Show me the like objective and and easily viewable corruption
coming from the state governments in the same way.
>> State governments are different sovereigns, aren't they?
Are state governments different sovereigns? I think that what
we're seeing right now is that a lot of state governments are
abiding hookline and sinker with the Trump administration. I
think that's one of the biggest topics that we've been talking
about over the last couple months. Where are you? >> Yes.
Now,
yes, it is about elections.
>> First, first in the context of election results, by
which you mean the count of votes, right? In the in terms of
the counts of votes, I'm not aware of Republican states uh doing
fraudulent ballots that said we should question their election
results. And I don't think that there's a track record of that
in such I wouldn't for in the context of of state elections.
That's perfectly rational. What's the next >> I think what
I think what you're doing is you're you're cycling in and cycling
out to get away from the fundamental question. And the question
is, this is number five, by the way. I brought it up before.
Number five, how wide is your net? Where do you draw the line?
Because so far your only justification is whether I like it or
not. >> No, no, no. That is not the only justification.
I just want to make sure Wick, you hear me when I give the explanation
to the extent of the scope of this negative inference. >> Okay.
So, I'm not just saying whether I like it or not. Okay. So, reason
number one, if there is a track record in a specific domain of
government action, all right, here in the context of investigations,
See, I don't know why Pisco I feel like what I said is way easier
to understand than what Pisco is saying. I just wish he'd say
what I said. Like obviously there's a bunch of reasons to believe
that the actions of this government, especially with regards
to subpoena and judicial power, is questionable. And that same
thing doesn't exist for the non-federal government, the state
the state bodies that run elections.
That's how you talk about it, right? >> Right. That that's
what government investigations. If there is a consistent track
record of lies and corruption, that's one reason to apply negative
inference. That isn't just because I like it, right? That's not
that
>> I You You're saying uh generally speaking, you're >> Oh,
never mind. Pisco laying it out this way is going to make it
very clear to this guy that he can't argue. I see. >> Defining
your realm as investigations. Yes, that's what you're wondering.
You're saying you don't like it? Investigations is so broad that
covers 100,000 people. >> Wait, wait, wait. Did I say Did
I say I don't like it or did I say if there's a track record
of consistent lies and corruption or is that the same thing as
I like it? >> No. No. However, what uh what you are saying
as I hear >> Okay. Wick, could you tell your guest to open
his ears and use his brain? Could you tell your guest to stop
being a to stop wasting my time? Stop pretending he doesn't understand.
He understands. Ask your guest, Wick, to like turn his camera
back on and slap himself in the face. Wick, if you want me to
continue arguing, ask your guest to turn his camera back on and
slap himself in the face now
because I believe that is the only thing that could wake him
up and get him to join the conversation and start paying attention.
Thank you. Thank you, Wick. spirit is that you think that the
uh Trump administration has uh used over and over and over again
uh the judicial branch in order to fulfill its political goals
in a way that you feel is improper or corrupt and therefore because
they have a pattern of behavior that we should >> by default
oppose whatever they do with >> all into question he didn't
say necessarily oppose to be clear >> I said you should
a negative inference >> negative inference and and so the
the reason I do this is I mean everyone understands in their
daily life if you have someone who consistently you over a student
who consistently you know turns in the wrong paper, someone who
consistently lies to you, a news source, by example, uh think
like Iranian state media that consistently lies or or North Korean
state media. This is not something bizarre to apply once you've
been shown to be so unreliable and so uh you know corrupt that
yes, this is not something that's insane to apply and it doesn't
make you an election denier to apply negative inference. >> What's
the difference between that and extra scrutiny? Because you made
it clear that that's not what you're >> Yeah. So the difference
between extra Yeah. I understand extra scrutiny to be uh maintain
a position of agnosticism, right? an agnostic position and before
you're going to be swayed in favor to have an extra threshold.
That's what I I take to be uh someone with extra scrutiny when
I'm fighting over nothing because
sorry no
so so so that's not the same thing because that's not what I'm
advocating for. I'm not advocating for you. I'm not So they're
different. So we don't agree, right? So they're different so
we don't agree, [laughter] right? I'm not advocating for you
to be agnostic and just apply a higher threshold before you believe
it. I'm saying negative disposition. No, wait. So these are different
positions, aren't they? They're they're not because the whole
reason why >> they're they're the reason the reason why
they're different is the reason why you would apply extra scrutiny
to something is because you don't believe
>> Do you understand the difference between agnosticism
and not
>> No, this guy
uh
No, it's not that you don't believe it. Although I would say
that's like my default position, but it's not quite that. It's
not quite that. Right. If I could identify something independently
that was true, I wouldn't really question it. when it seems dubious,
when it's targeting the Trump administration's enemies, and it
seems like slightly dubious, when you could see that it's not
being applied evenly, that's when the negative in inference would
lead to you going, "Yeah, I don't believe this. Yeah, I don't
I don't think this is real. I don't think this is serious."
Right? What I would say is
it makes sense to have the negative inference here and and nothing
is overcoming that negative inference. I'll back it up. >> Negative
disposition. No, wait. So, these are different positions, aren't
>> They're they're not. >> Oh, yes. It doesn't mean
that you can't believe the Trump administration is doing something
legitimate. That's why I said the thing about like obviously
you could independently verify that like Charlie Kirk was murdered.
So there needs to be an investigation into somebody there, Tyler
Robinson for example, right? We there are some independent verifiable
fact that allows me to go, "Oh yeah, sure. This obviously needs
to be investigated." >> So the whole reason why >> there
the reason the reason why they're different is the reason why
you would apply extra scrutiny to something is because you don't
believe it.
Do you understand the difference between agnosticism and not
agnosticism? >> Yes, obviously. But what I'm saying, you
you are intentionally applying a neutral tone to an investigation.
In fact, a reinvestigation. And what I'm saying is that the whole
reason to have extra scrutiny, and this is this is just we could
chalk this up to me not communicating it well enough. But the
the the whole reason to have extra scrutiny is because you don't
believe it in the first place. >> Yeah. So, I'm going a
step further, right? So, like
So, so I'll tell you why. I'll tell you why. Right. Like there
is a position that you could take and that position is in favor.
You could take a position that is against and you could take
a position that is I don't really know. I'm agnostic. I I withhold
judgment. Right? Those are all different positions you can take.
I understand a position of requiring extra scrutiny to believe
something to be a position ultimately the grounds out into agnosticism.
You see that that's different than being against it. I default
against it in in these domain. >> I I'm not describing
agnosticism. I'm saying initially I do not believe that this
is true. So I will apply extra >> Oh. So are you an election
denier?
>> I dude. Dude,
[screaming] dude, what is wrong with this guy? How did he not
see what he was JUST HOW DID HE NOT JUST SEE WHAT HE'S WALKING
INTO? >> This is This is my point though. I I like when
you accuse me. Now we got the same [laughter] when you accuse
me of We actually have the same position. Bishop, >> I
was You were leading me to believe that you were arguing something
further than extra scrutiny. I'm not even I am >> No, Bishop,
think of it like you're like [laughter] if you're a debate moderator,
you're going to take everything they say with extra scrutiny
if you're trying to fact check it. Even if like you're third
person or like if you're not like let's say Caitlin Collins is
trying to like fact checker is trying to do extra scrutiny to
make sure all the debate people are like telling the truth but
if you're uh doing a piece that's not that's not quite true like
if Rob Moore tells me something I'm going to have extra scrutiny
for it but I generally believe something negative >> inference
but also say [laughter] no but the difference
what what what makes this thing is I started off disbelieving
the judicial actions by the Trump administration against this
on I thought this is and I told people this right I think this
like this doesn't seem to be something that there is a legitimate
case for. However, the argument made today has reminded me and
I've looked into it more and things like that where okay, actually
there's enough of a plausibility here. It's high highly likely
that I have gone from being against Trump to neutral in the situation.
I'm not pro, >> but I am now neutral. I now I [laughter]
don't have enough information. No, you started started with something
I've been wanting to say for a while. I'm I'm so sorry, Fishy.
This is something I've been wanting to say for a while. I really
wish that I could take the soy pill's entire perspective on this
issue because I would say philosophically I started from where
the soy pill is. The problem is that with my experience and knowing
how a lot of this stuff works, I find it virtually impossible
that he didn't talk to somebody and have a conversation worth
worth asking about. I would say if I look, if I was in an intelligence
officer and my job was like the Cuba desk, I would want to question
every single American that is coming in and out of there right
now. If anything, just to be like, >> why didn't they do
that, Bishop? Yeah, but they didn't do that. This is mandatory
process. This is >> You're right. But the I say a political
program raises the threshold from your average person. >> No,
no. I'm saying you could have you could have asked about it.
You could have sent an inquir. You could have sent him a letter.
You could have sent a >> No, a subpoena has a force of
law. It's a mandator. [laughter] >> Okay. Like that's what
I'm talking about. If it was up to me, I I would I would want
to talk to every single person. However, I think that the threshold
can rise when you are doing a political program that is officially
collaborating with the Cuban government. This isn't like my friend
uh Tyler Panel whose uh whose wife is from Cuba and he regularly
goes to Cuba and they just go into and visit his family. This
was a this was an entire uh political program. >> Wait,
how do you know they're not how do you know he's not doing that?
>> I I I know that he's not in a political program that
has been
>> How do you know? There's less reason to suspect that.
>> Okay. Shouldn't we shouldn't we subpoena him? Is it
not plausible that he went to a bar and talked to someone? >> Once
again, I think that there is value in talking to every single
person. I'd be curious and be like, "Hey,
why?" Yeah. Why? Why don't we just subpoena all of us? >> What
is this question? You guys are playing stupid. I've said it four
times and it's so it's like I'm talking to people that are intentionally
acting like they don't know what I'm talking about. No, no, you
can you can talk to people. No one's stopping you from talking
to Hassan or talking to all these people, but what happened was
there was an issuance of a subpoena and at least allegedly there
was pre-clarance with the Office of Foreign Asset Controls. And
in that context, I'm just not sure what what you're saying is
well, there's an interest in talking to people. Why is that as
which could be true of anyone traveling to Cuba? Why is that
justification for the issuance of a subpoena if it I mean the
greater includes the lesser here? Why wouldn't it justify his
opinion everyone who goes to Cuba anytime? >> I think I
think I think he wants to right if you want to sub >> you
would want a subpoena.
>> Okay, but that's not the position of the Trump administration
of Nick Shirley. >> Every single individual. >> No,
I wouldn't want to subpoena.
>> Surely surely something distinguishes this. I would
want I would certainly I would want to talk to every single person
that goes there and I would want to subpoena anybody that is
involved in high level political programs deeply involved with
the Cuban government and military. Yeah, absolutely. >> As
a
gohead, sorry. >> No, no, no. That's what you're saying.
>> I was going to say like if if what you take is that
there's like a default presumption that if you go into high level
communications with members of the Cuban uh I don't know government
or
>> Yeah. So, I mean, if that's your view, is there maybe
there's evidence that Hassan had high level communications and
you would therefore want to subpoena him instead of like asking
him about it or send him a letter or saying sending a request
for documents? Um, I mean, I just don't think that this is a
standard that the administration is actually applying. I think
what the administr I think there's no question that if Hassan
were someone that were sympathetic >> and basically would
just need evidence that that's the standard they are applying,
which actually I think might have come out since this interview
started or since like in the past couple hours, somebody who's
saying that they basically haven't sent any subpoenas. They've
done a request for documents essentially, which to me I'm like,
okay, that seems that seems kind of fine if it's not like compelled.
Okay. Okay. >> He would not be hit with a subpoena. And
I take politically motivated investigations to be repugnant to
the constitution. And that's something >> So are you are
you asserting that there is no difference between Hassan going
to Cuba and my friend Tyler Panell visiting his f his wife's
family? >> I'm sure there's no difference. Why did you
say I'm sure I didn't say that there was no difference. In fact,
the reason in fact I'm saying the opposite, right? I said that
there is a difference and the difference is right and this is
one that I I think is obvious is their sympathies towards the
president. Their >> so I would I would say that a more
important difference is that one of them was in an official program
that was collaborating with a hostile foreign government and
the other one isn't. That's that's what >> Hey, why why
didn't they subpoena Brian
>> Brian Grim? I I didn't do that. >> I don't Yeah,
Brian Graham. >> No, I I don't know why they didn't subpoena
every single person on
that >> Being a journalist, so I feel like that would be
Well, journalist couldn't possibly talk to a guy in a bar. That'd
be great. >> What's the difference between Brian Graham
and Hassan? Why didn't they? He's a leftist. He's a leftist.
>> There's honestly not as big of an influencer, I think,
as
big. They're like, "Hey, we can we can go after these people,
right? >> This is this but this is like if your
>> to be honest, I wouldn't be shocked if somebody Fox
got a heads up about some like an investigation into Code Pink
and threw Hassan Piker's name in there just to get keep him in
the news cycle just because like, hey, there's a lot of interest
for these Hassan [__] stories. Can we work him? Can
we just throw him in here? You know, we'll just throw him in
here real quick. >> Is that the Trump admin? >> I
would love to see Maybe we have to go back and check because
I think I have the article from yesterday. Can I go check the
language on that article? What is it saying? Uh an inside source
is alleging that
right. What's the language on the article? Is it strong language
or is it very very very weak language of like possibly it is
becoming there is an early source reporting that possibly maybe
in some university or sorry some
how did I say university I'm I'm trying to read and talk I'm
reading chat and talking at the same time never a good >> cracking
down on it political opponents and trying to chill anyone from
going to Cuba or helping Cuba and also using it as a vector to
attack its political opponents Ryan Grim certainly qualifies
as a political component that they want to attack and a vector
to chill people. So the question you have to deal with
and not I'm happy to answer that. Yeah. For the same reason in
the context of what they did previously with immigration and
going after Mahmud Khalil and going after Amaze Auster because
you don't have to get everybody. You can go after particular
targets and you go after people who are unsympathetic. Hassan
is more unsympathetic than Ryan Grim. Ryan Grim has the extra
extra credentials of being a real journalist. I mean let's be
honest here. Uh Han is not a journalist and there's probably
more of an institutional protection of them and so yeah they
go after weaker targets that >> Wow.
Wow. Impuging impugning the journalistic credit of my guy Hassan
[__]
this group of libs peo
I see how it is I see how it is man >> less sympathy uh
coding people right those aren't sympathetic people to most individuals
in the country and so all of that I think explains why you pick
and choose your targets and that doesn't mean that it's not chilling
right anymore liberals are more likely to be like you know what
I am okay with them going after that's the exact reason you're
liberals be okay with them going after Ryan Grim and some of
the other tech I think you get a lot I think Ryan Grim would
get a lot more push back from the liberals and they did this
because
That's crazy. >> No, I I [laughter] don't think you think
Assan is less or equally as hated as Ryan Grim. >> I think
he is. >> But if they're still in no
for me, and I can only speak for me. I think that Ryan Grim is
far more insidious than for a lot of reason. >> I think
it's not about what you think is more is worse. Right. >> Most
Americans don't even know who Hassan is.
>> People know who is than Ryan Grim. More people he's
more famous than Ryan Grim. A lot of these cases you you've created
a disprovable scenario based on what follower count. >> I
don't No, no. >> Now we're talking about disprovable scenarios.
Mr. Got met in a bar and exchange intelligence. >> No,
[laughter] this is what I'm saying. This is what I'm saying.
You're there is no impossible standard. As a fact of life, Hassan
told people that he was in direct communication with the Cuban
government. That is something he said. >> When did he say
that? >> This is not
>> direct. He's in direct communication with the Cuban
government through a proxy.
I like okay actually
I don't even know if it's just one proxy because like I I do
believe if that's going through the like OFAC as well if all
communications are going through a government approved entity
then is that a problem
>> he said so he can get his internet right >> yeah
he and let me let me rephrase that in some kinds of legal terms
he is in direct communication with the Cuban government to receive
privileges >> fact is it a fact that Nick Shirley was in
a sanctioned hotel he wasn't supposed to be in >> fact
well don't get me wrong if you want to sit here and tell me that
this dog government is not going after Nick Shirley when they
should be. I'll agree with you all day. That [laughter] is not
If you if you grant that though, if you grant that they're not
applying the law equally, that's repugnant to the Constitution.
That's repugnant to rule and equal protection and and we should
be against the whole thing to put >> That's not how it
works. It's like so so if they if they wrongly investigate, they
stalk somebody day and night for four years because they're trying
to get him for murder and then they get him for murder and that
was wrong because they stalked him for four years. All of a sudden
we can't have problem with murder as a whole. No absent absent
abs absent compelling evidence that distinguishes the cases.
Absent ev compelling corroborating evidence. I am going to apply
negative inference to this regime and and until they show me
that the way in which you know object an objectively neutral
person might distinguish the conduct here. I'm going to assume
that they didn't have an objectively good reason to objectively
>> what's up. >> I was going to say this. I was going
to say wick the way you described your like thing was 100% what
Pisco said. But I wanted to say I honestly if they they didn't
do it for China which was weird but my thing is weird. If they
did for China or Cuba, I would be like, "Okay, I kind of get
some validity." >> Because they want to do war with Cuba.
I mean, isn't that the most obvious thing in the world?
>> I mean, they do want to go to war with Cuba right now.
And maybe that is another reason that a subpoena or request for
documents could make sense. >> And that's why they're doing
they're all trying to not get like trying to have the upper hand
on you. But if you went to like if you went to like uh Ukraine
and they did this, I'd be like, "Okay, that's wild." But I feel
like the two I feel like if you did it for China or Cuba, I was
like, "Okay, I definitely understand some type of >> They
didn't do it for both." actually is to me uh kind of pushes me
towards that there is something legitimate here if their purpose
was to target Hassan [__] right? They would have
done it after he came from the CCP, right? >> Everybody
would have everybody would have said he deserved it after he
came back from China. A sound bite of him saying I'm not particularly
patriotic to the United States. Are you kidding me? >> Vishy,
we're going to clean it up. I love you, BUDDY. BUT TWO BUCKS
two bucks ain't enough.
>> So So So let's talk about that, right? You're saying
this is not political because I mean they didn't.
>> Does the US restrict restrict where you stay in China?
Is there a list of pre-approved hotels and for you to stay in
in China? Is that a thing that exists in China?
Cuz I could have sworn that that the US trades happily with China,
that there is no embargo on China. Doesn't that imply like a
very very different relationship with China where you wouldn't
be able to apply anything like this? Like, isn't it totally moronic
to pretend that the same investigation would happen because you
went to China?
>> I'm not saying that. I'm saying that for me, for me,
right, I do not know and I do not have enough information to
make a legitimate decision here. And what has pushed me towards
that is again I start from the position that whatever Trump is
doing is corrupt when it comes to the judicial system. That's
my starting point. But there has been enough uh stuff to kind
of push me to the side of well now I'm I'm unsure. And one of
>> wait, to be clear, wait, >> dude. The Justice
Department is opening a criminal investigation on Eene Carols
of 3 hours ago. It turns out Trump, they really do like it when
you grab them by the or they go to jail. If you don't like it
when I grab you by the you're going to jail,
get ready for it,
>> Wait. No. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. You move
probably or might not be doing something illegitimate because
there's a plausible scenario where this could be okay. Not maybe
Trump is illegitimate. And also there's a plausible thing because
that's my position. >> I think it's likely. It's not just
plausible to me. I think it's likely. It's 60/40 if they wanted
to chill uh people uh having positive relations with Cuba or
having a positive view of Cuba or helping Cuba in these ways.
They would have gone after everyone there most likely. >> No,
that's not true. Wait. So when they went after law firms, did
they go after every single law firm? They went after
Trump's enemies. They did. Every single >> No, they didn't.
No, that's not what occurred. No, they they they picked and choose
the ones either that Trump hated the most or for whatever reason
were more outfront in terms of their opposition or let's say
they helped Hillary Clinton on a matter and when they did that
other firms that weren't specifically targeted were >> Dude,
if only there were ways to tell that these people's political
opinion was worthless before this doobie. Oh my god. Like when
they totally disavowed somebody for violating their friends and
then crawled back to them when they realized they couldn't make
it as a streamer over time. >> Like maybe that one. I don't
know. And that's also true who saw what was happening to Harvard
and other schools and you didn't need to go after every single
school to get compliance. Same thing by the way when it came
to immigration did they need to go after every single green card
holder who criticized um the Israel policy? No. They picked and
choose and everyone else got the message. And for you to say,
well, in order for me to think that that's their need to go after
similar way people, you're really dumbing it down. You're really
dumbing it down. You're just you're you're you're dumbing it
down by removing a lot of variables and factors and you're just
you're essentially saying that, oh well, when they went after
the law firms, they just went after a couple of them. It's like
no, there was factors there factors and variables that went into
who they target and why they target. For example, as we discussed
before and with Hassan that there are variables and factors that
differentiate Hassan from other people that go beyond his follower
count. >> So So I I'm really just trying to get you guys
to understand the one singular point I'm making here, which is
the following, right? Just because you haven't shown that they've
attempted to uh do a specific action as to people who are similarly
situated doesn't mean that they're not trying to chill. No, it
doesn't necessarily mean that, but I think that it suggests to
me that it might be the case. >> Why Why does it move the
needle on you at all if they've picked two test cases the same
way, by the way, that they've done in other instances before?
>> Because I see I see no I see no >> It looks like
we're 5 minutes away from Lykan hopping in. I'm not sure where
the argument goes. We'll see. >> Downside for them to just
subpoenaing the meal. Like I see no significant political hit
that they would take from doing that. There would be no downside
to doing that. Yeah, there going >> there's not a huge
outrage about this. >> Yes, there is. What are you talking
about? There's like a whole like media swing and if you think
if they didn't go after more journalists who had more
hated as a biker that they wouldn't get more push back, I don't
think there would be any more. >> I think your intuition
here is incorrect. I think that if they had gone after every
single person on that flotilla that needle wouldn't have moved
in any significant >> really that's I mean
a strong
>> it would just be the exact same if they went after everybody
in that flotilla. It' be the exact same guys.
Why do you think that?
>> So it does apply in the situation that the more you
paint with so the more people that you you get involved the less
likely that you're going to have uh you know a unified opposition
against you know particular individuals because those people
have their own networks have no all I'm trying to tell you is
that it's true on both inferences. It's true on both worlds.
It's true in the world in which they're chilling that they might
not go after everybody and it's true in the world in which they're
not chilling that they might not go after everybody. Right. So
everything you've said are neutral to meal evidence. Wick wick
wick. Do you think they're trying to create a media chilling
effect? Do you think they're trying to create a media chilling
effect when they go after Jimmy Kimmel? >> Just Jimmy Kimmel?
>> Why? It's just Jimmy Kimmel. >> Yeah, it's just
Jimmy >> because he's not just Jimmy Kimmel to be clear.
They've gone >> No. What do you mean the thing? A bunch
of people said a bunch of trust, but they just went after Jimmy
Kimmel. So I mean like right like it's just because the line,
right? Again, there's no legitimate case for this in but in the
>> in the instance here there is >> this is once
again I I can't paint I can't paint a scenario for you right
now that something that Jimmy Kimmel said might have incited
violence that there is a much no grant you that do you think
there's a scenario that Jimmy Kimmel might have said something
that a show host Wick do you think that Jimmy Kimmel could have
said something that incited violence against Republicans >> not
in any meaningful
not a plausible scenario not a single by the way that's not what
anybody says is obviously you are incurring some increased risk
of somebody getting shot in the head when you call them a fascist.
The issue is what what trade-off is more important to you. If
I call you a fascist and I mean it sincerely and I lay out reasons
I think you're a fascist and obviously the implication of fascist
is like Nazi Germany uh our enemies. I am obviously doing that.
The unfortunate thing is so long as it's descriptively true,
so long as I'm accurately describing you
and on top of accurately describing you,
I believe it like that is more important. Preserving my right
to that speech is more important than not increasing that risk
very very slightly.
Right now, I don't think it's a big risk. I don't think you add
very much to the risk. You certainly can't be held responsible
for somebody taking that action, especially when you principally
disavow that action. But of course there is some tiny tiny tiny
piece where you are increasing that when you say something like
that, right? The issue is the world where you let that prevent
you from speaking the truth is a world you don't want to live
in.
>> I did not say I did not say equal. >> Yeah, exactly.
I could say man that Trump guy really stinks. And probably in
some tiny minuscule infantismally small way I'm probably increasing
the chance that somebody blows Trump's head off. But I'm not
I don't. I think that's awful. I don't I would never suggest
that. It is both morally and pragmatically repugnant and terrible
and and awful for your movement to even lean into those things.
Okay. I
>> What if there were a trial of some kind?
>> Okay. I'm going to I'm going to mute all of you unless
you shut up right now. I'm putting my moderate back hat on. Peace
go give your statement and then once you've given >> he's
accusing me of bad faith and he has no he has no basis to do
that when I said ape strong together. Clearly the point there
is to suggest that there are downsides to going too far and getting
people who and instead of isolating individuals who can be uh
chilling targets. That's what that statement meant. There's nothing
bad faith about it. You just can't contend with the >> That's
that is that shows how small your mind is that you think I can't
contend with that. It is a [laughter] >> Yes, that's my
strategy. I just called the other person a first. You're just
too dumb to understand me. THAT'S MY STRATEGY. LET'S GO. I'm
back on the Lockheed liberal side. People [laughter] thought
it was bad. It is bad faith because you could say that about
>> I have to let Bush respond uninterrupted. Go ahead.
>> You could say that about literally anything. It has
no there is no value there. There is nowhere for that conversation
to go. There is no there is no response to that. There's no analysis.
That's why I said I don't even want to talk about
Bishop. That was a Bishop. What was a response to you all saying
there's no plausible reason why they would avoid subpoenaing
everyone there? >> No plausible less plausible.
>> Well, I I don't know how you make that determination,
but basically that there's no cost entailed in subpoenaing more
of these people. Yes, that's my >> Yes. So, you guys had
you guys succeeded that there's no real cost. There's no significant
cost in painting with and getting all these people and subpoening
them. And what I responded to is actually isolating people is
quite effective. A strong together. The more people you have,
the more likely you're going to get them to rally up against
you. That was the response there. I'm not trying to say that
that's what you would I'm trying to say that it's your false
contention that there is no strategic advantage to isolation.
That's what I'm trying to get at and it's a >> What are
what do they gain by isolating
>> Of course. >> You think that it is easier to go
after an individual and not have to defend why you're going after
every single person if they all have different reasons, different
backgrounds and different like characters that need to be defended?
Do you think it's not easier to pick the easiest weakest person
who has the most reason to be attacked for other reasons like
that the administration has gone after? You don't think that's
easier than if you went after literally every single person?
easiest person. The weakest attack. The easiest weakest person
on that trip is somebody that we couldn't even name on this panel.
The idea that might make no no easiest weakest in regards to
they're the easiest to attack. They're the easiest target because
they have all this smoke against them. Even Democrats are going
against Assa for very
effect. Wouldn't Wouldn't it be a chilling attack if they if
they went after a bunch of non-millionaires and said Trump administration
is persecuting large swats? Because that's harder for them to
defend. >> It's harder for them to defend. If you did Yes.
If you did all of them. It's not. It's literally not against
Hassan. Wait, this is first of all, you can disagree with this
position. >> The entire reason they're doing this is dude,
I don't even think they have any intention to like go after the
like Hassan really. I truly believe this might just be Fox News.
The reason they're picking Hassan is because it's Hassan. That's
why they want Hassan. >> But what I take issue with is
your notion that it's bad faith. It's bad faith to say that there
could be interrupting and go after Hassan [__] You've
been interrupting and talking over people and using bad faith
arguments since a >> guy's getting aped and he doesn't
like >> You got in here one bad argument, >> dude.
Dude, this guy got so
obliterated on the Oh, are you election Are you an election denier?
He got so obliterated by that he can't handle